In the early 1960s, high school athlete Dick
Fosbury probably never imagined that he would
set the Olympic high jump record in 1968.
The then teenager at Medford High School in
Oregon participated in the high jump portion
of track and field, but as a sophomore, he
failed to clear the 1.5 meter height required
to qualify for a number of high school track
meets.
The standard high jump techniques of the day
included such techniques as the straddle and
the upright scissors method.
In the former, the jumper takes off from the
inner foot to pass over the bar with their
face down and legs straddling it.
While American high jumpers at the Olympics
used the technique to earn themselves silver
and gold medals, Fosbury could not coordinate
his limbs and body just right to make it over
the jump at any great height.
Straddle Method
Thus, he began experimenting with another
high jump method- the upright scissors technique.
Jumpers using this method approach the bar
at a thirty to fifty degree angle before taking
off with the outside leg.
The leg nearest the jump remains straight
and swings over the bar, and the takeoff leg
is swung up over the bar once the jumper crosses
it.
Jumpers often bend forward at the waist once
their takeoff leg clears the ground to lower
their center of gravity.
Scissor Method
With neither of these methods working terribly
well for him, Fosbury began experimenting
with different jumping techniques, achieving
greater heights than he could with the standard
methods of the day.
One such method became the Fosbury Flop.
When Fosbury developed this innovative backwards,
headfirst leap, it was quite by accident.
He later stated,
It was just simply intuition.
It was not based on science or analysis or
thought or design.
It was all by instinct.
It happened one day at a competition [in May
of 1963 at the Rotary Invitation at Grants
Pass, Oregon].
My mind was driving my body to work out the
best way to get over the bar….
I can remember the coaches looking through
the rule book that day to see if what I was
doing was legal, which it was.
I ran into that over the next couple of years
in high-school competition: the opposing coaches
checking the rules.
If you’re wondering why this method had
not been long since discovered by other jumpers,
going over the bar headfirst and backwards
meant that Fosbury would be landing on his
back, something that would not have been possible
before his junior year.
You see, high jumpers prior to the early 1960s
landed on surfaces made up of sand, sawdust,
or woodchips, meaning you at least needed
to partially land on your feet or risk injury.
To get around the injury problem, colleges
in the United States began bundling up soft
foam rubber inside mesh nets in the late 1950s.
These bundles not only provided a softer landing
zone, but they stood about three feet tall,
making it so jumpers did not need to fall
as far on the way down.
Just prior to Fosbury’s junior year, his
school replaced its old wood chip filled landing
area with such soft padding, making his otherwise
back breaking flop viable.
Despite his success with the method, Fosbury’s
high school coach initially insisted he keep
practicing the straddle technique, but stopped
pestering him when he used the flop to break
his high school’s high jump record, clearing
six feet, three inches (1.91 meters) and then
shortly thereafter clearing six feet, five
and a half inches (1.969 meters) at a state
competition.
western-roll
Western Roll
Fosbury’s subsequent college track and field
coach at Oregon State University in Corvallis,
Berny Wagner, also tried to get him to abandon
his flop, for the entirety of his freshman
year having him practice the western roll
technique (where the jumper lifts themselves
into a horizontal position over the bar).
However, Fosbury was allowed to continue using
his own technique at competitions.
Things change when, during his sophomore year
in the very first meet of the season, Fosbury
flopped his way to a new school record of
6 ft. 10 inches (2.08 meters).
After that, Fosbury stated, “Berny came
up to me and said, ‘That’s enough.’
That was the end of Plan A, on to Plan B.
He would study what I was doing, film it,
and even start to try to experiment and teach
it to the younger jumpers.”
It was while he was in college that Fosbury’s
jumping technique became known as the Fosbury
Flop.
Fosbury later explained how his method got
its name:
To tell the truth, the first time that I was
interviewed and asked ‘what do you call
this?’
I used my engineering analytical side (Fosbury
was a civil engineering major) and I referred
to it as a ‘back lay-out’.
It was not interesting, and the journalist
didn’t even write it down.
I noted this.
The next time that I was interviewed, that’s
when I said, ‘Well, at home in my town in
Medford, Oregon, they call it the Fosbury
Flop’ – and everyone wrote it down.
I was the first person to call it that, but
it came from a caption on a photo that said
‘Fosbury flops over bar’.
Before this, one newspaper noted in a caption
showing one of Fosbury’s leaps, “World’s
Laziest High Jumper.”
Yet another described his jump noting that
it looked like “a fish flopping in a boat.”
Nevertheless, five years after first flopping
his way over a high jump bar, this former
teenager who for a time couldn’t even qualify
in certain high school meets, used his innovative
method to get himself on the United States
Olympic Team for the Mexico City Olympics
in 1968.
At that Olympics, he was one of only three
jumpers to clear seven feet, two and a half
inches (2.20 meters).
With only three competitors left, he then
managed to clear seven feet, three and a quarter
inches (2.22 meters), along with his teammate,
Ed Carruthers, while their Soviet Union competitor,
Valentin Gavrilov, did not and ended up with
a bronze medal.
fosbury-olympicsThe bar was then set to 2.24
meters, a height Fosbury cleared, setting
a new Olympic record.
Carruthers failed in all three tries, winning
Fosbury the gold.
Not satisfied, Fosbury then asked that they
put the bar up to 2.29 meters (7 ft. 6.12
in.), just over the world record of 2.28 meters
held by Valeriy Brumel.
(Brumel had his career cut short in 1965 after
a motorcycle accident resulted in serious
injuries to his right foot.
Even after a whopping 29 surgeries on it,
his foot never recovered enough to allow him
to jump competitively again, though he did
attempt a brief comeback in 1970.)
For Fosbury, beating Brumel’s mark was a
leap too far and he failed on all three attempts
to clear the bar.
Nevertheless, with Olympic gold in hand, the
track and field world took notice of the Fosbury
Flop.
By the 1972 Olympics in Germany, twenty-eight
of the forty high jumpers were using this
method.
The 1980 Olympics saw thirteen of its sixteen
high jump finalists use it, and today, while
other techniques can still be seen used by
those warming up, when it comes to actual
competition, some slight variation of the
Fosbury Flop is the gold standard, and not
a single person who’s used a different technique
in the high jump has held the world record
since 1980.
So why is the Fosbury Flop so much more effective
than previous high jump techniques?
Jumpers who use such techniques as the straddle
method need their entire body to be above
the bar when they reach the peak of the jump,
meaning their center of gravity is also far
above the bar.
While there are many different subtle variations
on the flop, in general, at the apex of a
jump, when their center of gravity is at its
highest point, the jumper’s legs are still
below the bar on one side while their head
and torso are below on the other.
If done optimally, and with sufficient flexibility,
this means at no point does the jumper’s
center of gravity need to go above the bar;
in fact, at times it can be several inches
below at its peak point, requiring significantly
less leaping power to produce the same result
as techniques that require the jumper’s
center of gravity to go higher to clear
the bar.